so collective commutation is how we
think biological systems solve problems
but before delving into what collective
commutation is it's worth stepping back
and thinking about the big picture
so in physical systems physics is
dominated by concepts like pressure
entropy and temperature and these arise
from simple collective interactions and
provide huge insight into how the
universe works in biological systems
there are similar collective concepts
like metabolism conflict management and
robustness but unlike in physical
systems these are functional concepts
and whereas in physical systems order is
generated through the minimization of
energy in biological systems there's the
additional step of information
processing why biological systems have
this additional step and whether
information processing makes them
fundamentally subjective and therefore
uncharacterized able by laws are big
open questions in C for my research
group here at SFI we think that
biological systems overcome this
intrinsic subjectivity by computing in
evolutionary developmental or learning
time their own macroscopic worlds in
other words consolidating regularities
to do work more efficiently examples of
collective computation include the
coherent behavior that arises at the
whole working as a level from the firing
decisions of the billions of neurons in
your brain it includes the features of
social structure like the distribution
of power that arrives from the status
signaling interactions in chimpanzee and
macaque groups and which have huge
implications for how conflict is managed
it includes the collective motion of
fish schools that arises from the
alignment and velocity decisions of
individual fish and it includes the gene
regulatory interactions in micaiah derms
that produce robust features of
phenotype